Benzema en équipe de France et c'est
Alain Ducasse qui vient faire une pige
au McDo quoi
j'accueille maintenant Gaspard Proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et oui et oui et oui ah je suis je suis
content je suis content de te voir c'est
moi aussi si tu es là c'est que tu as
retrouvé du boulot quoi
non mais c'est vrai enfin mais il est il
est là pour pour une pièce de théâtre ah
ouais
c'est pas encore ça non mais faut être
lucide le théâtre c'est quoi c'est c'est
foyer Emmaüs du cinéma quoi
c'est vrai c'est vrai la SPA des
producteurs parfois ils adopte et puis
ils font un deux trois films 4 puis
après on voit l'acteur attaché bordel
l'autoroute des vacances comme ça enfin
dans le jargon ça s'appelle un téléfilm
sur TF1 quoi
enfin bref la semaine alors cette
semaine nous avons été à 11 septembre
c'est une date très très importante
l'anniversaire de Bachar el-Assad
et on comprend mieux certaines choses il
est vierge alors maintenant sachant que
sa femme est née le 11 août la seule
vraie question qui se pose c'est quoi
est-ce que ça peut durer entre un vierge
et une lion
cette combinaison peut fonctionner très
bien le lion peut offrir l'imagination
et l'excitation alors que la Vierge peut
offrir son esprit d'analyse son sens de
l'ordre
c'est et nous on veut briser ce couple
[Applaudissements]
mais
quand qu'on les laisse s'aimer
[Rires]
tout ça parce que Hollande il prend la
guerre en Syrie pour un jeu vidéo
d'arcade à trois niveaux tu sais le
niveau simple c'est le Mali tu sautes
sur les dromadaires du manioc
en Syrie tu rajoutes le paysage urbain
puis troisième niveau très difficile là
c'est Marseille tu attrapes un guetteur
de rue
je me disais à propos de Bachar qu'on
voulait punir détruire supprimer
vraiment à la shlag quoi
Bachar par rapport à la réforme Taubira
c'est quand même bizarre de vouloir
mettre en place des peines de probation
pour des délinquants reconnus coupables
en France et en même temps envisager la
peine de mort pour des suspects présumés
innocents à l'étranger
[Applaudissements]
le sport évidemment je pensais important
de parler aussi un peu de
pelouse il y a un malaise Benzema dans
l'équipe de France arrêtons de la câbler
et le mec il gagne 8,5 millions d'euros
par an auréal équipe de France tu
touches 15000 euros par match astérife
il est déjà gentil de toucher la balle
[Applaudissements]
Benzema en équipe de France et c'est
Alain Ducas qui vient faire une pige au
McDo quoi
alors après l'équipe de France n'est pas
toujours irréprochable dans ces demandes
dans ces complainte so to say elle se
plaint d'être mal aimé c'est sûr que
c'est pas en allant au [ __ ] que tu te
fais une idée complète de l'amour quoi
le bon coin oui aux États-Unis des
couples revendent des enfants qu'ils ont
adopté et les revendent sur internet
alors jusque là pourquoi pas mais en
revanche les argumentaires de vente je
suis tombé sur une annonce je cite j'ai
honte de le dire mais le détestons
vraiment cet enfant
c'est quand même malheureux de vendre
ton gosse comme ça je veux dire si tu
vends une voiture tu dis pas vends
voiture pourrie qui n'a été qu'une
source d'emmerde
alors forcément je me suis retiré des
enchères j'ai pas j'ai pas éducation
payons Vincent a sorti sa charte sur la
laïcité ça ne va servir à rien et il
faut que les gens puissent s'identifier
là il citer laïcité personne connaît la
cité des 4000 les Tarterêts mais laïcité
alors payons veut refendre les
programmes ça c'est la marotte des
nouveaux ministres des Dédé qu'ils
arrivent quand tu arrives à l'éducation
nationale tu refais les programmes c'est
l'éducation nationale c'est le seul
endroit où les mises à jour rendent le
système moins performant qu'avant safari
un éléphant a tué un vieillard avec sa
trompe en Seine-et-Marne c'est pas
étonnant en ce moment tu sais les
éléphants ils quittent les hauts
plateaux de Picardie pour aller
rejoindre le bassin francilien faut
vraiment respecter l'équilibre fragile
de cette région c'est un écosystème
d'une beauté absolue quoi spectacle
extraordinaire bon récemment je suis
allé en baie de Saint-Malo voir
l'accouplement des crocodiles
c'était sublime c'est quand tu vois le
crocodile affalé comme ça et que
l'Improviste un ours polaire qui passe
il y a une
[Applaudissements]
sport toujours
Kevin le fait jusque là ça ne dit rien à
personne c'est normal c'est un attaquant
du Red Star qui souffre d'une fracture
du nez alors c'est un petit jeune qui
monte juste envie de dire la coke c'est
avec une paille pas avec un marteau
c'est cinéma
la rentrée d'Alain Delon qui a déclaré
que l'homosexualité était contre nature
dire ça au 21e siècle faire l'apologie
de l'hétérosexualité
pour Alain Delon l'homosexualité contre
nature il a fait Rocco et ses frères
non mais je veux dire comment est-ce
qu'on peut encourager les
l'hétérosexualité quand on sait que
statistiquement monsieur suth il vous le
dites jamais tous les délinquants je dis
bien tous les délins sont les enfants
d'un couple hétéro
en débat on vous l'a jamais fait cela
pas encore
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est grave c'est grave que
fait Pierre Berger
économie alors la police vient de
démanteler le plus grand camp de Rome à
Lille en fait les flics ne sont plus en
concurrence avec la gendarmerie mais
avec des mécos ça devient les types ils
savent plus arrêter un coupable en
revanche ils savent parfaitement comment
on fait bouger une caravane ou une
armoire normande c'est
alors les robes il y a un endroit très
simple pour les reloger c'est toujours
un problème il pourrait faire partie de
l'expo permanente du Salon de la
caravane Porte de Versailles et ben
voilà
mais moi ah l'Allemagne va renvoyer
devant la justice les gardes du camp
d'Auschwitz
à l'époque les mecs ils avaient 21 ans
enfin faut se remettre dans le contexte
en 40 en Allemagne gardien de Caen
c'était un emploi d'avenir
amour de vieux ont été retrouvés ligotés
dans une maison voilà ce qui arrive
quand on joue des jeux SM et qu'à cause
d'Alzheimer on a oublié le mot de passe
pour dire stop
[Applaudissements]
alors bonne nouvelle de la semaine un
bijoutier touche un braqueur je tiens à
rassurer tout le monde le scooter marche
toujours alors ma belle la vie et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu